the average number of calories that we
eat per day is about 2,100 kilocalories
per day okay and that's energy per unit
time kilocalories per day so energy per
unit time is what we call power in
physics not the Washington DC kind of
power but power for physicists is how
much energy are you burning up per unit
time and if you calculate how much that
works out to it's the same thing as a
hundred watt bulb
so a watt is a Joule per second and if
you calculate how many joules you burn
up in a day at 100 watts that works out
to be 20 100 kilocalories per day so if
you have a like if there are three
people in the room and it gets warm it's
because they're generating 300 watts of
heat it's like having a 300 watt bulb
going on so if you multiply a hundred
Watts by 6.8 billion which is the number
of people on the planet you find out
that the whole power generation of the
human species is about 0.68 terawatts ok
terawatt is a lot of watts let's see you
know I'm there's kilowatts megawatts
gigabytes gigawatts and then terawatts
so it's it's a lot our domestic animals
if we are 0.68 terawatts our domestic
animals are about twice that so that
makes it about 1.4 terawatts and then if
you look at all of the domestic all of
the inanimate energy that people produce
it's about 15 terrawatts so you should
think of each person you see as a parade
of 25 people
first there's the person and that
person's energetic consumption
immediately behind our
people who represent the domestic
animals on average that that person is
responsible for and after that there are
22 more people who represent the
inanimate energy okay so 1 plus 2 plus
22 is 25 so why are we transforming the
earth because we have 7 billion people
but each of them has 25 shadows
energetic shadows so it's the same as if
the earth were covered with 175 billion
people that's how we are transforming
the earth animals are a part of that
their equivalent of 2 of those people